ان هذه الحرب التي ما تاخذه منا وبسقوط
ابنائنا وبناتنا العزاء دوله
اسرائيل على موتهم من ثلاثه الون شمري
سامر طلقه
و عندما بلغونا عن هذه الماساه
الكبيره الون سامر
وتام نج من نيران لمده 70 يوما كانوا على
وشك ان يكونوا في الحريه وان يكونوا وهنا
حدثت
الماساه ما فطر قلبي
وفطر قلب الامه جميعا وقلوبنا هي مع
العائلات في ساعتها الصعبه هذهه الصعبه من
المهم ان ادعم
قواتنا يعملون من اجل تحقيق انتصار ناصع
حاسم على العدو واعاده المخطوفين سنعمل كل
شيء من اجل ان نحافظ على الجميع كل واحد
منهم جميعا سنستخدم كل الوسائل ومن اجل ان
لا
يصابوا منذ الماسا
بالامس تراود فكره ماذا يمكن ان
يحدث ما كان امر اخر انا متاكد ان هذه
الفكره مشتركه لنا جميعا كانوا كانوا
قريبين او كنا قريبين جميعا من ان نحتضن
ولكن لاسف لا يمكن اعاده الزمان الى
الوراء كل من حارب في ساحه القتال يعرف ان
بين النصر والماساه هي شعره في هذه الحزن
الكبير سنست خص العبر
و نتوقف ونتخلى عن الهدف السياسي والعسكري
من اجل اعاده مخطوفين بسلام الى الوطن مع
كل الاسى والحزن
الضغط العسكري هو مهم ايضا من اجل دا
المخطوفين وايضا من اجل تحقيق الانتصار
على عدو دون هذا الضغط العسكري لا يمكن ان
نصل كنا الى اتفاق من اجل اعاده المخطوفين
وايضا مواصله الضغط العسكري سيؤدي الى
اعاده كل مخطوفين التوجيهات التي اعطيها
الى ققم المفاوضات اعتمد على هذا الضغط
وبدون ذلك ليس لدينا شيء مواطن
اسرائيل سضان الشمعه الاخيره من عيد
الانوار في هذه في هذه الايام النضال من
اجل اقامتنا و وايضا هناك في الزمن البعيد
حققوا الانتصار على العدو وايضا في هذه
الايام في قتالات صعبه في جباله وشجعيه
وخانيونس ومناطق اخرى سقطوا المكابيون في
هذا الزمن في النضال ضد العدو الذي يريد
تدميرنا فقدنا ابطال كبار محاربون وايضا
ابطال وابطال سقطوا في ساحه القتال وايضا
من اجل ان نستمر نحن في الحياه ومن اجل ان
يكون مستوى حياتنا عالي مع معكم مواطن
اسرائيل احتضن العائلات الثه وابكي
معهم انا كعائله الثكل حتى يومهم الاخير
لن يكون سيشتاقون الى اعزائي ولن يتوقفوا
عن البكاء على من فقدوا
ايضا تحدثت مع مع زوجه تومر فيلد
قائد الكتيبه 13 الذي سقط ببطوله مع جنوده
قلت لهم ما اقول لكل اخواني من العائلات
الكله انا اعرف ان الالم في قلوبكم لن
يتفع الى الابد ولكن هناك اس من ان نؤكد
ان ابطالنا لم يموتوا سد وان نواصل الحرب
حتى تحقيق الانتصار
الحاسم اكدت هذا التصميم ايضا للمستشار
الامني القومي للولايات المتحده الذي
التقيت معه باول امس واشكر الولايات
المتحده على تقديمها من اجل ان نحيد
مخطوفين وان في الامم المتحده لمنع
المحاولات وايضا اعود واقول لاصدقائنا نحن
مصممون من اكثر من
اي ان نواصل حتى على حماس وحتى نعيد كل
مخطوفي وحتى ان نؤكد انه في غزه لن يكون
هناك مصدر يبول الارهاب ويرسل الارهابيين
وانا اقول لكل العالم وايضا الكثيرين في
العالم يفهمون ذلك وانا اؤكد هذا المساء
ايضا هذه هذه ليست سياسه هذه هذه منهجيه
منهجيته واقول لكم ان هذه رغبه كل معظم
الشعب لن نعطي الفرصه ان تكون حمسان وفتح
ستان في ان نبدل خانيونس ولم
نعطي نعود الى خطا اسو وايضا ان نعيد الى
غزه الجهات المتطرفه التي التي تسعى الى
القضاء على دوله اسرائيل والذين يربون
اولادهم على هذا الهدف النقاش بين فتح
وحماس بالقضاء على دوله اسرائيل هو كيف
يقومون بذلك
ايضا 80% من استطلاع لراي العام
الفلسطينيين
يبررون المذبحه في السابع من اكتوبر وحتى
هذه اللحظه كبار السلطه الفلسطينيه يرفضون
يرفضون ادانه هذه المذبحه وهم سولون على
غزه اليوم بعد اليوم كرئيس لوزراء اسرائيل
لن اعطي لهذا الامر ان يحدث من المهم ان
ننقل ذلك الان بانه بين الاصدقاء يجب ان
نقول الحقيقه و نكون هناك في اوهام وايضا
الاهم فيما امر يتعلق بامر مصيري وانا
اعود واقول لاصدقائنا بعد القضاء على حماس
قطاع غزه ستكون منزوعه السلاح ستكون تحت
سيطره امنيه اسرائيليه ولن يكون هناك اي
جهه يربي على قتلنا والقضاء علينا اريد ان
اقول لكم مواطني
اسرائيل ان الانتصار ياخذ وقتا ولكننا
مصممون ان نواصل حتى النهايه
وب والاس قلوبنا ايضا الضغوط الدوليه نحن
سنواصل حتى النهايه لا شيء سيوقف حتى ان
نحقق الانتصار معا سنناضل ونحارب وباذن
الله سننتصر معا